oh hey there Nick hey lice fancy seeing
you here I don't often see you down
these parts now where's that old bull of
yours it's a beaut over there then won't
that light blue spinnaker spinnaker you
say now what's that is that one of those
whiz-bang new gizmos I should be knowing
more about a spinnaker and you call
yourself a sailor
your Buccaneer a spinnaker
is the front seal of your boat you know
what else it is what spinnaker is an
open source multi-cloud continuous
delivery platform for releasing software
changes with high velocity and
confidence let's jump to a demo
so this is a spanker dashboard and on
this dashboard you're able to see the
resources that spinnaker manages in this
case we're managing resources on Google
cloud platform and we're actually going
to exhibit a demo which is a developer
pushing code into a release branch
having that release branch be built
tested validated and then promoted into
production and then deployed into
production so you see here we have to
load balancers an ingress load balancer
for a staging environment as well as an
ingress load balancer for a production
environment both of these are hooked up
to Google kubernetes engine clusters and
you'll see here they're both running the
same go application with a white
background just exhibiting the text
hello world so let's say I'm a developer
and I want to release a feature change
to this application in this case we're
just going to change the background
color from white to yellow and to do
this I would just jump to my source code
I go ahead and adjust the index.html
file to go from white to yellow or in
this case light yellow and then I would
just push this commit into my version
control for this case I'm using github
so we just go through the standard git
commands and we add a commit to say that
we're adjusting to light yellow and then
once we actually push that into our code
base we're able to kick off our CI CD or
continuous integration continuous
deployment pipeline so I just go ahead
and log into github and then from here
we'll kick off that process so if I
hover back into the actual Google cloud
platform console you'll see here that we
have a tool known as Google Cloud source
repositories and what this tool does is
allows you to mirror github repositories
within Google Cloud backed by reliable
durable object storage if you see here
we've already noticed that commits that
I pushed into github and you'll see that
commits adjust to light yellow
background and here this is B notice
almost in real time from here we have a
container register to build trigger
that's basically monitoring that Cloud
repository and building a container
which will be our docker artifact that
will then deploy into the communities
cluster so you'll see here there's a
trigger that's MA during our github repo
so we created this docker image it's
been built just now it's 288 megabytes
in size and we tagged it with two tags
one latest and the other one md5 hash
digest of the commit ID so this is where
spinnaker comes in what spinnaker does
is that it modders a docker registry and
when there's a new image that's uploaded
to that registry it'll kick off a
pipeline so if I hit the refresh button
we should see a pipeline for deploying
to stage that's about to be run so
you'll see here it's now running so this
stage what it does if you see over here
it's monitoring that docker registry or
that Google container registry to see
when I image is actually uploaded there
once it detects an image has been
uploaded and then begins the deployment
process so here you can see we're
deploying it to our staging environment
using a red-black deployment strategy so
this takes some time to complete we're
going to take a quick break and I'll
come back once it's completed all right
and we're back and you can see that that
deployed a staged step completed and now
we're held up at this validate stage
what's awesome about snooker is that it
gives you the ability to have a human
intervention in your pipeline so you
have the manual judgment step which
allows you to approve this pipeline and
move on to the next step when you've
confirmed that you're saving environment
looks good to go
so go back to our cluster side we'll
click on that ingress load balancer find
that IP and I still have that open in my
tab
so I'll go to my top right and check
this page when i refresh this it does
show that we've made that change and it
is now a light yellow background if you
look at if we looked at the production
environment we'll see that still showing
white background so we'll say this is
good to go
we'll hit continue and that'll basically
go to that next step we've confirmed
that we validated that the release stage
is good to go and now we're at the point
where we're comfortable to promote to
production so in this promote to
production pipeline we have numerous
steps and this also takes some time to
complete but insurers are able to do a
reliable as well as a repeatable
deployment so I'm going to pause the
video we're gonna come back once it's
completed and there we have it the
promote to production stage has
completed and at this point we should
have that pristine docker image deployed
into our production career DS
environment so we go back to that
load balancer I still have that tab open
with that IP at the moment it's still
showing white but when I hit refresh it
should go to light yellow there we go
so at this point we've done in NC n CIC
deployment from source code and to build
steps release into a staging environment
and then promoted into production and
spinnaker is what makes this all
possible
I thought I knew everything about
sailing and GCP but boy I was wrong
if you're working on cool projects you
want to get in touch with us click on
the link below to contact us till next
time
[Music]